hello everyone we're glad you joined us
for today's live webinar overcoming the
clinical sample bottleneck for
expression studies presented by doctors
markman re and Sean deal i'm kristina
jolla blab roofs and i'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminars is presented by
lab rooms the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
and sponsored by eight metrics atha
metrics technologies enable multiplex
and simultaneous analysis of biological
systems at the cells of protein and gene
level facilitating the rapid translation
of bench top research into clinical and
routine use for human health and
wellness Ava metrics part of thermo
fisher scientific provides leadership
and support parting partnering with
customers and pharmaceutical diagnostic
and biotechnology companies and leading
academic government and nonprofit
research institutes in their quest to
use biology for a better world to learn
more please visit www com ok let's get
started this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions to the speakers during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window once dr.
maneri and dr. diehl finished their
presentation we will open it up for live
QA to enlarge the slide window click on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or you
can report your problem by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
we have two speakers for you today mark
Maneri MZ and sean deal PhD dr. Minnelli
an American pediatrician who had worked
in sub-saharan Africa for most of his
professional life was educated
at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology and Washington University
School of Medicine in st. Louis he runs
the basic science lab in st. Louis and
maintains three active field research
teams in Africa in Sierra Leone malawi
and lona dr. Mary is the Helene
Robertson professor of pediatrics at
Washington University and has published
more than 175 peer-reviewed articles
improved gut health has been his primary
focus in the past five years dr. maneras
professional goal is to fix nonya
nutrition for kids in Africa to this end
he has developed ready to use
therapeutic food and novel lipid-based
foods that has been accepted as a
standard care for uncomplicated severe
acute malnutrition by the UN agencies he
continues to explore the basic
pathophysiology and metabolism of
mammalian skimming malnutrition and has
developed a new diagnostic method to
measure hosts transcript and feces using
sensitive micro array and pcr
methodologies chopper deal is an
assistant professor in the Department of
Medicine infectious diseases and
associate director for research for the
vaccine testing center at the university
of vermont he received his PhD in cell
and molecular biology from the
University of Vermont and did his
postdoctoral work at the academic
Medical Center of the University of
Amsterdam in the Netherlands his
published 30 peer-reviewed articles and
serves as a reviewer for NIH and the
congressionally directed medical
research program at the University of
Vermont vaccine testing center doctor
deals overarching research goal is to
develop novel indicators of how
vaccination triggers the immune response
to promote durable immunity and
protection from disease to develop novel
correlates of protection particularly
for infections of global importance such
as dang and Zika viruses rotavirus and
other pathogens she's also been
investigating how conditions such as
malnutrition impact the infant immune
system
and has recently developed a workflow
that allows for hg a 2 point 0
microarray analysis a field preserved
small volume pediatric whole blood
samples the speaker's complete BIOS are
found on the lab roots website dr.
maneras will begin his well now began
his presentation dr. Manari great thank
you so much Christie for the kind
introduction and I'm delighted to have
the opportunity to talk this morning
what I'd like to talk about is using the
human transcriptome as elucidated by the
a microarray to diagnose a very elusive
condition called environmental interrac
dysfunction huge mouthful of complicated
words there but we're going to go
through them and help you understand
exactly what this is all about we're
going to talk about stunting which is
child enemy number one and environmental
and tarek dysfunction as a cause of
stunting the whole transcriptome
analysis in in pieces as possible and
reliable and show you that methodology
and interpret it to define the
pathobiology and then how we can use a
focused pcr technique which was driven
by the microarray to as a biomarker for
this condition so as we get started
stomping is global enemy scourge global
health scourge number one affects
roughly thirty percent of children
worldwide under by it refers to in a
literal way having short stature but it
really implies a whole host of deficits
which are overall on devastating so
we're talking about counting for twenty
one percent of disability left adjusted
life years among all kids we're talking
about something that predicts poor
cognitive function for kids in Africa
stunting affects about half of rural
children in Africa is a real continent
remember Africa is a half and are sixty
seventy percent excuse me how kids are
are stunted sorry we've had some
technical like it I'm back on here okay
and far stuntin goes the stunted
children are less likely to attend
secondary school and their life they're
going to earn twenty two percent less in
terms of their income their life
expectancy seventeen percent last and
this cost the main IQ points so overall
this is a huge huge huge huge problem
and when we think about growth and
development the the paradigm that I've
got here is a three-legged stool and on
this platform supported by three legs
you have good growth and development you
need each leg to be strong and
sufficient in terms of the to allow for
good growth and development and two of
these legs are things that we've known a
lot about for a long time the one unread
on the right is a diet that provides
adequate amounts of micro and macro
nutrients in bio available forms the one
on the left the blue one it requires
that you don't have an excess of common
infections and these common infections
are not some kind of chronic infections
a chronic illness but they are things
like malaria diarrhea little respiratory
infections but if you just have too many
of these you don't grow at the same time
you're having an infection so you won't
grow and develop and then the third leg
here which is kind of mysterious on the
green side is called good gut health so
what do we know about good gut health
well i would say that a year or two ago
we would show you these pictures that
you see here and on the right side you
see poor gut health and on the left side
you see good gut health you see
something that looks different you see
the shape of the villi are our law in
good health are long
and they the shape on the right side
with the poor guy how are blunted reduce
surface area the working surface area of
the of the gut is it absorbs nutrients
is decreased if you stain these things
for immunological cells you'd see that
there's a lot more inflammatory cells in
the bad gut health side but it was
that's really big and and what causes
that or how we can affect that what
pathways are driven by that how we can
detect that are all thoroughly
mysterious to us until we started using
the microarray ok so the Tet the wake up
health is measured at present is
something called a loculus mannitol test
which is a dual sugar absorption test in
other words these sugars that are not
metabolized we get children to drink
these and they look for these sugars in
the urine because they're not
metabolized so one of the sugars
represent is absorbed across the surface
area the mannitol the monosaccharide and
that gives you a sense of how much the
surface area of the gut is the lack ulos
which is a disaccharide is um leaks in
between cells and paracellular junctions
so that the lactulose is a sign of the
integrity of the cells in a cell
adhesion and this is the standard tests
than a way to measure poor gut health
and it is you can see here on the left
the bar graphs show you that if you have
a good electoral mannitol test in other
words low loculus high mannitol then you
have good growth on the y-axis here
we're measuring your linear growth and
if you have some moderate disability you
have some compromise growth but not but
still good but if you have severe ee d
then you would have we do your diet
reductions in your life
growth such that you would be losing
compared to your counterparts and thus
the numbers there are the right are
meant to show you that in in different
kind of modeling exercises that the LM
test is a very important predictor of
linear growth so what we did though is
we decide to took a population for
investigation and these are rural
African kids and it was alluded to in
the introduction that I maintain three
field teams and about 150 employees and
spent actually most of my time working
in Africa although I'm employed by
Washington University to look at what um
ed is and you can see here on this slide
near the bottom these are kids who are
under 5 these are kids who about twenty
percent we would say have good gut
health and twenty percent have severe uh
ed and most of the kids are moderate and
this is typically what we see in rural
Africa more than half of the children
are affected by this poor gut health
typically the way they live these are
folks that live in you know mud huts
with grass rules they're not they don't
live in electrified structures they have
often have domesticated animals that
they keep in their homes at night for
safety improved homes might have a use
of a pit latrine or a borehole for water
source so unfortunately a very common
living scenario for kids in Africa and
really important factors associated with
poor got help so we wondered if we could
use stool samples to find out what the
host what the body was doing in
environmental enteric dysfunction okay
so first you have to wonder about ken an
RNA a messenger RNA survive survive and
its present in stool samples and that
this will have to be preserved in any
special way right away and that's what
this graph is showing you on this slide
there have the colored dots are
are all the very same sample that has
been flash frozen at different points in
time from 0 to 24 hours and on the
y-axis you can see two different RNA
transcripts toll-like receptor for / gap
th which is a housekeeping gene and and
then you can see that these dots
overlaying each other pretty pretty well
so in other words if you get a stool
sample and you preserve it and by making
it cold in four hours or eight hours
that's probably quite adequate for for
RNA and even though they are enabled a
grade a bit with time the ratio of two
RNAs in the sample remains pretty
constant so that was encouraging to us
to save it that this particular kind of
biological sample was relatively stable
and wasn't going to be greatly affected
by the way we collected it and if we
look at the preparation that we use we
mean it we go ahead to that slide to
start with here if you look at the the
pie chart over here look at the rnase in
stool in human stool and you see most of
it is bacterial and most of it is
ribosomal in fact only a quarter of one
percent are coding hosts rnase so we are
looking for a needle in a haystack okay
so whatever method we use to isolate
this RNA we're going to have to be very
conservative we can't throw half of it
away because there aren't wearing any
transcripts in there to detect and this
method over here shows you how we were
able to do that you're not really need
to view the details here but we're
prepared to answer those questions this
has been put forth a couple times in a
peer-reviewed publication for as well to
share this methodology but it's a little
bit on standard it's not how you would
say prepare a sample just for pcr so we
give some differential centrifugation
and
extraction on a bead based technology
okay if you are going to look at the
transcriptome agnostic alee you would
probably in this day and age you would
look at RNA seek or high seat procedure
so this basically takes all the
transcripts in the stool off of which
you can see on the graph they're mostly
autumn or bacterial and amplifies them
and detects them okay so that is
something we tried with fecal samples
and we were utterly failed at that we
just cannot just distinguish any
meaningful differences in there in bear
in mind i didn't didn't emphasize it but
when i showed you that picture of good
and poor gut health that's the upper
intestine most things that come in the
feces are from the colon and the lower
intestine so we're really really really
really looking for a needle in a
haystack here with these hosts
transcripts associated with poor got
hell so we turn to the HTA and we
actually had used an earlier version not
successfully but the HTA 2 point 0
advantage of using the microarray is
that it is going to preferentially bind
human and just let the bacterial stuff
wash away and the HTA arrays as you may
learn more about it is a basically a
chip with six million sites and this
each site is a 25 mar and the 25 were
sort of marches systematically through
the human genome offset by a couple of
basses so you know basis well 12 25
basis 32 27 and so forth and this goes
through coding non-coding the whole the
whole genome so we've got a picture of
the whole genome now there are multiple
duplicates on the array there are so
our additional sites to helping to
identify certain important variants and
splice junctions so it's a very complete
look at the transcriptome and then the
method which we use for the microarray
that that I think is illustrated here on
this cartoon you can see then the
preparation was just to isolate the RNA
very conservatively and apply it to the
array and then you get all these these
different luminescence values for six
million sites corresponding to these 25
MERS in our case we could detect about
18,000 different different genes and
these are not whole jeans on the array
but of course they're just fragments of
genes and so there's a way to aggregate
these into related sets and then also
the related probe sets are then
aggregated into jeans and then once you
get these signals you have to do
something with them and and those are
choices that bioinformatics asst can
make and instance this was very new
ground I would have to say when we when
we did this and maybe even today most
people are skeptical that you can
reliably do anything with feces we chose
three different normalization methods
their RMA iron and farms and if you're
familiar with those kind of things that
there are amazing the most common most
standard and iron is also pretty common
and then we look identified transcripts
that were associated with our LM test
which is our marker measure a
quantitative measure of Ed we looked for
differential expression we look for
correlation coefficients either
Pearson's or horse spearman's and we
required that any candidate gene
actually be showing up is related on on
all of these different from particular
qua criteria
and then we can use those set of genes
that are up or down regulated to map
them to biological pathways either
canonical pathways or or keg pathways
and and then we can get our to get a
picture of what the host is doing any ed
so to start with i would say that we we
wanted to see that if we ran the same
sample twice did we get the same answer
and that's what this picture shows you
it's indeed true the blue lines at the
top we're telling you that if you pick
it take a piece of tissue which we know
that these micro arrays are made to deal
with um what do you get and then the red
lines at the bottom are showing you when
you take pcs ok so the the x and y axis
represent the same sample being run on
two different micro arrays ok so we've
run the same sample twice we get the
very same answer reproducible and
detectable this picture here shows you
that the the pattern of signal intensity
between tissue and feces is more similar
than it is different ok so this is the
shape of these sets of bars is what
we're looking at here and you can also
see that the one in the middle one
normalized by the iron method that one
is most similar so we often focused our
results on iron normalization as well ok
so both of these two pieces of
information encouraged us that we were
getting something reproducible and and
reliable so we would then have to learn
whether we could interpret this into
something meaningful we used to validate
the microarray we had to use a PCR
technique which was quite sensitive
called digital drop pcr and this is
where you set up a normal PCR reaction
and then you sonicated in oil and then
you get all these little bubbles and
then
bill aqueous bubbles usually about
20,000 of them and you then count each
of those bubbles be cut with your
fluorescent probe as either with light
supper it doesn't light out and that is
a very good way to look at low copy
numbers of transcripts which is exactly
what we're dealing with remember we're
dealing with the needle in a haystack
putting a very low copy numbers here so
we validated this on this slide here we
show you that for 40 or 50 or so
different transcripts that you get the
same result the open bars and the dark
bars are very similar in the correlation
coefficients between the microarray as
well and the DB pcr of the very same
samples okay so now we believe that
these are actually measuring on
transcripts and measuring them
reproducibly well we then went on to
look at about 260 kids with varying
levels of Ed and as I said ed is going
to be a condition that's not discreet
you don't have it or you don't have it
but you either have more of it or you
have less a bit or you have a lot of it
or you have very little of it and we
quantify that with an LM number and you
can see that we identified several
transcripts here we have 18 by DDP see
on looking here on this slide with these
216 microarrays you can see depending on
the normalization method we identified
do about 600 600 650 that are correlated
with the lactulose measurement that are
differentially expressed to his numbers
of about 150 to 300 and then correlate
and then in pathways that were in up or
down regulated up or down expression
excuse me of cagar canonical pathways so
this sum is right away it's pointing to
something that is not a condition of
they would say be like a specific
infection okay as specific infection is
probably going to have fewer pathways
and fewer transcripts upward express the
purpose of this heat map here is to show
you on the right side there's more red
and that's that there are some
transcripts that are will express more
often in children with severe ed and the
right side of it there's some more blue
which some transcripts are not expressed
much and then the picture down here with
all the list of 12 or 13 transcripts
that are most strongly and consistently
associated with EE D if you look down
what those transcripts do you'll be
impressed that they do um they really
engage the whole spectrum of the human
immune system so we see responses to
bacterial infections viral infections
fungal infections parasitic infections
and this indicates that this ed is not a
single infection but somehow the barrier
function of the gut is going to be
disrupted and that's what's causing this
problem and then this picture here shows
you the pathways the canonical ones on
the right and the cake pathways on the
left that we're expression was changed
with Ed as opposed to noe ed and you can
see the types of pathways have to do
with immunological activation but also
cell adhesion barrier function integrity
so this tells you something else about
the path of biology of it and so we can
elucidate this with several transcripts
of interest here and it's not important
that you read off any of these are all
of these but to know that some of these
are involving mucus layer production
the Slayer integrity some of them were
immune system activation like
calprotectin some of them are just
enzymes that particularly are expressed
in the small intestine so something that
that differentiates a small intestine as
opposed to the colon and some of them
are for growth of the small intestinal
cells so when I showed you that picture
at the beginning about it being fairly a
opaque we had no idea what was going on
in ed that was a couple years ago and
after doing this study with the
microarrays you can see the same picture
at the bottom here but now we're able to
draw a cartoon above it and we're able
to get a pet an understanding of what's
actually going on in ed which is as I
say a central cause of stunting all
worldwide so you see in the cartoon on
the Left we have normal upper small
bowel barrier we see there's a thick
mucus barrier there's a layer of
commensal bacteria and those to prevent
the contents of the lumen and the
microbes in the lumen from interacting
with the surface allowing the surface
just to absorb nutrients the immune
cells are waiting in in reserve there
then you move over to the right side of
this cartoon and you look at that and
you see what's going on ed we've
disrupted that mucus barrier we have
lots of exposure of enteric pathogens to
the gut epithelium we have the
concomitant breaks in integrity and /
increased permeability and the host
response that you see written over here
on the far right in the slide is what we
learned from this microarray technology
yet that there's recruitment of diverse
immunological active cells especially
particularly viruses so we often focus
in
magic of the microbiota relating to
bacteria but the viruses really seem to
be a prominent here in AED and of course
diagnostically looking at the host
response gives us clues about that which
say doing metagenomics or something with
bacteria won't compromise mucus layer
and then a top apoptosis and and death
so this particular story that I told you
is is very very powerful so we started
this a couple years ago not knowing
really what was causing this but knowing
that it was incredibly important for
children of worldwide and now we have a
very clear insight into the path of
biology because of what the microarray
is able to show us and and we did
certainly take the microarray and push
its limits so when we pushed it to a new
application that probably wouldn't be on
the package insert or something but
we've then since taken that and with
some clinical risk factors we've
identified a biomarker of Ed so that
when we do the biomarker of course we
are going to do it by pcr we're not
going to run out a whole microarray
although you could imagine that a custom
microarray would probably be useful in
this matter and you can see we have six
transcripts down below they can
represent a diversity of functions in
the upper small intestine mucus layer
some reg one a is a structural protein
in this only in small bowel calprotectin
is an inflammatory response as well as
T&F zone and that I think should bring
in this to a close lots of people to
thank in this and these are always the
most dangerous slides the
acknowledgments comes for every name up
there there's going to be you know
tendon to attend you haven't so
mentioned but in particular we use this
application for debate dividing a new
biomarker for the bill and melinda gates
foundation for AED and we couldn't
certainly have done this without the
support of affymetrix as they gave us
many of the microarrays to work with and
we're now currently looking on a large
intervention trial with legumes which
the usda is funding leggings because
there could be a food that heals this
barrier function and would not be
special because these leggings would
then be an avenue to preventing stunting
not only by their nutrient content but
what they're doing to the milieu of the
cut surface so i've talked for a long
time so i'm going to stop now and turn
it over to Shawn thank you dr. Maneri I
will now hand it over to dr. deal for
this presentation dr. deal everyone hear
me there we hear me all right switching
to my slides now okay so thank you all
for being here so in is actually a
really nice dovetail with a with marks
talk and so again it's going to relate
to HT a two point oh and new
applications for this under the theme of
overcoming the clinical bottleneck for
gene expression studies and in
particular what I'm going to be talking
about is analysis of gene expression
tissue that's ubiquitously available not
quite the same level as stool but
nonetheless blood but presents its own
troubles and that we walk you through
what we've looked at over the over the
last few months in trying to understand
transcription analysis and a whole
pediatric blood so it's just some quick
disclosures affymetrix has provided a
little bit
technical and partial material support
the project has been funded by the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation and a pilot
grant from the Vermont senator for
immunobiology and infectious disease so
the background here is and again
understanding some some more things
about infant survival and thriving and
so across the world unfortunately still
about four hundred and fifty children
under age 5 die from infections
worldwide now vaccines have come a long
way in preventing disease but these
regiments are very long complicated and
are one-size-fits-all as illustrated by
this scheme here from the CDC and for
American children this is relatively
easy to to fulfill with with access to
to healthcare and clinics etc but in
rural areas in the developing world this
can be very complicated to achieve and
so leaving a lot of children unprotected
so a goal in the end here would be a
deeper understanding of infant immunity
and the factors that affect it in order
to try to understand aid in improving
vaccines vaccination schedules
increasing adjuvant set cetera and
assessing risks to infectious disease
which is a major goal of many
individuals in the global health field
and so as my pediatrician friends tell
me infants are not little adults
especially in terms of the immune system
and so there are a number of different
things that are quite quite
significantly different in the infant
immune system compared to the adult
immune system and so we'll start here
with in the upper right is sort of the
humoral immunity so B cells are an
important part of humor and durable
immunity production of antibodies and
specifically in infants there are a
number of defects such as a lot of
immature transitional cells smaller
production of high-affinity ana
bodies and germinal centers and that is
partly precipitated by less help by T
cells for b-cells and so and then with
regard to the t-cell side there are a
lot of immature thymic cells and
immaturity cells that are that are
present in the infant circulation
results in a is associated with a lower
ratio of th1 which are cells that are
capable of infighting intracellular and
and viral infections and th2 being very
important for bacterial infections etc
and this ratio being in balance as is
necessary for in addition protection
from infection but also reduction of
autoimmunity and allergy later the
innate immune system is also affected
and so particularly with its ability to
stimulate these th1 responses and so on
the bottom end of this spectrum here in
our sort of external environmental
factors all these things can affect in
the development of infant immunity and
so there's you know the premature birth
or the season in which you're born
whether it's the the wet season or the
dry season in utero stresses the pote
the early postnatal environment maternal
antibodies that that mom has is
transmitting through breast milk or
during the first six months after after
birth through transposon till igg can
also have a negative impact on the
ability of an infant to mount a strong
vaccine response and the one that I'll
discuss is is a is one that dr. maneri
introduced is nutrition it's an impact
on the immune system and so malnutrition
in and of itself increases a child's
risk of dying from infection by about
four to ten fold
and work from from us and others have
shown that malnutrition going to be
associated with an increase in pro
inflammatory biomarkers and can be
associated with lower titers to
important vaccines like the oral polio
virus and and also again this increase
in pro-inflammatory cytokines you have
to command room with this is that in in
the scope of things most most kids are
moderately malnourished that's sort of a
Poisson distribution where there's a lot
of modern malnutrition and of course
some extreme malnutrition and in
moderate and malnutrition which affects
the most children the humoral components
the total amount of antibody present the
accessory factors that help antibodies
mediate their function which is
complement immune cell numbers these are
all relatively resilient to moderate
malnutrition so there's a but it the
hypothesis here is that the that these
cells may be less poised that baseline
are able to act when our face with a
with a insult in the context of
malnutrition and that's what we're going
to be looking at today and so the aim
here is really to determine whether a
transcriptional profile in blood can
reveal a distinct baseline gene
expression signature that's associated
with malnutrition and so the approach
what we have from a large field trial is
a whole blood from one-year-old infants
and we have separated them into groups
infancy exhibited a control growth
trajectory versus an impaired growth
trajectory and are going to be looking
at whole genome transcriptomic analysis
so I made a monologist and so I really
like doing in vitro functional
experiments too and we have some
cellular samples from this patient but
they are very limited there's you get
one shot at that that's a very small
volume of pbmc s and so our our thought
process through this is that the gene
expression profile in blood can help
inform so
functional assays and that we can be
doing with the paired pbmc samples and
the long term rationale is that in
identifying some malnutrition related
impacts on gene expression can yield new
biomarkers critical signaling pathways
and new targeted approaches for
supplementation in specifically in
malnourished kids and and some of this
would dovetail very well with what dr.
maneri introduced is macro and
micronutrients supplementation etc could
be something that we could look at in
terms of the modulation of these
critical pathways and so the project
that we're working with is the is the
performance of oral and of rotavirus and
oral polio vaccines in developing
countries so the provide study and the
the bulk of this was took place as a
birth quarter of above 700 children in
the capital of bangladesh called dhaka
so these children were followed from
birth to two years old with clinical
visit with clinic visits eat the
diarrhea etiology and severity monitored
routinely immunogenicity of these oral
vaccines as well as other systemic
parenteral administered vaccines
peripheral biomarkers i'm using an
outdated term should be environments on
Terok disorder as mark binary alluded to
but environmental a neuropathy was the
former name of that nutritional status
is indicated by anthropometry primarily
how well the kids gain weight or gain
stature and maternal and socioeconomic
factors as well and so in so just as a
brief overview of what i mean by growth
here is here's an example of the on the
left is the weight-for-age z-scores that
the wh 0 has available for
for the for the world essentially it's a
one-size-fits-all although there are
country-specific graphs that are
available and so basically the way this
works is the age on the x-axis the
weight in kilograms on the y-axis and
then these dotted lines are the our
standard deviations above the median
growth that's been averaged over over
children across the world to these
specific ages and the traditional
definition is the is this red line here
where the waz dropping below a score of
minus two standard deviations below the
median is is the typical definition of
malnutrition and in the provide cohort
on the right we see we'll see waz as
well as a height for age z-score and
wait 48 weight for height score and so
an orange here malnourished kids the waz
of less than minus two is about
twenty-five percent in about one year
life kids who are stunted so haz score
of less than minus two is about thirty
percent at one year of age and children
exhibiting wasting disease are about
eight percent of our cohort with a
weight for height z-score of less than
minus two and so we wanted to then
investigate whether malnutrition it can
be correlated with any of the bio
markers etc vaccine responses that we've
looked at so this is a recent
publication where figure from a recent
publication where we measured here on
the over here on the vertically grossly
put into vaccine responses and on the
bottom here factors such as biomarkers
anthropometry and background factors and
so what we so these include serum
cytokines ferritin an indication of iron
uptake
calprotectin was measured my latest Lila
peroxidase here reg 1b gut health some
micro nutrients such as vitamin D zinc
c-reactive protein soluble cd14 which is
a marker of LPS or bacterial infection
and then also some of these other
factors such as maternal height and
weight the the height and weight
profiles at an early time point and then
correlation with titers and responses to
common vaccines such as measles
pertussis diphtheria poliovirus
rotavirus so that also here was another
way of measuring growth which is the
change in height or weight over the
first year of life and so what we found
is that when we looked at the weight and
height we found through this smoothly
clip todavia smoothly clipped absolute
deviation score which is a statistical
method that is designed to maximize the
impact score of significant biomarkers
and minimize those that are only
tangentially related and so what this
the blue color refers to a positive
association of two factors and the red
indicates a negative association so the
way this works here with height is you
see some blue popping up with pertussis
diphtheria tetanus oral polio virus to
titers etc and then another just trying
to use my mouse here to advance the
slides oh here we go and so on the in
the other direction if you look at the
absolute change in height or weight over
the first year of life and identify
factors here over here on the left in
red so these are all negatively so
associated so what this means here is
that if there's a low weight or height
at vaccination this is associated with
reduced polio diphtheria dtp vaccine
responses and if on the other hand if
there's a low rate of change in height
or weight during the first year of life
there is an association with increased
pro-inflammatory cytokines like
interleukin-1beta syriac and and also
the biomarker c-reactive protein soluble
cd14 and then fared in which may which
is maybe a metabolic indicator which may
indicate some sort of generic infection
going on and so with having identified
an association of malnutrition
information and immunity we then
proceeded to the whole blood samples to
get more insight into the systemic
immune system baseline and so for blood
of course it's a familiar and routine
procedure can be termed a liquid biopsy
where there's longitudinal sampling
possible it's a host a wealth of
information including immune and
inflammation markers in as well cells
and and then and also other soluble
mediators the the challenge with gene
expression whole blood is that what you
really are interested in at least I have
it as an immunologist are really the
white blood cells so these leukocytes
here so that's where most of the
functional information will be it will
be available but leukocytes are about a
thousand times less abundant than
erythrocytes and a hundred times less
abundant as platelets and so again
similar to what markers describing in
stool with bacterial ribosomal RNA being
the predominant feature even in blood
where there is really no other foreign
contaminant it's really fighting with
between erythrocytes and platelets and
so the
isolation the way you could get around
this is the isolation of the pbmc s but
that's not always routine in field
settings and can be often difficult in
small pediatric samples and in some of
the challenges of whole blood without
doing isolation of pbmc is that erythro
sites a particular very high levels of
hemoglobin alpha beta mRNA which are
highly stable due to modifications and
the untranslated regions and in fact
some recent papers using RNA seek have
been shown to wear 8052 eighty percent
of the reads are derived from globin RNA
so you lose power so this was a new
procedure for us and so our approach was
to take in our pilots study 30 control
subjects 30 malnourished subjects whole
blood at one year of life there are
gender balance we use the HTA 2 point 0
arrays and then i also have a outline of
how we put our batches together since we
can do about 10 micro arrays per day we
didn't want to have batch to batch
variation and you can review that at
your leisure but as Mark indicated the
HTA 2 point 0 arrays give you a whole
genome coverage alternative splicing and
at the University of Vermont we've
identified that HT a 2-point OS similar
sensitivity and assessing full changes
in gene expression compared to RNA seek
it's much more cost effective to be
quite honest and in fact our pilot study
with only 16 subjects was underpowered
for a single nucleotide polymorphism
analysis and so all this led us to HT a
2 point 0 and so the first step was we
used we did our isolation are in the
field what was done as is a procedure
that was designed to maximize our a
stability so actually quite a lot of
tries always used and the field
preservation where as it should be a
three to one ratio this was about a nine
to one ratio and so this is a little bit
different so first the whole blood was
resuspended in
aizawl and then frozen at minus 80 and
then on the left here we did it with a
column prep typical kaijin column prep
and then on the right with standard
ethanol precipitation and so the way
this was done was saw the blood sample
in the water bath adding 1 ml of rnas
teenage free water to try to decrease
the contaminants that are present in
whole blood removing a couple of alec
watts and then comparing the yields
banana drop and what we found here was
that the yield was higher after ethanol
precipitation and actually resulted in a
slightly cleaner profile so this was
ethanol precipitation was routine and
able to provide enough RNA for us to
work with so next we this is a two year
study and so the samples could have been
stored for quite a long period of time
and so we wanted to test whether the
stability of the samples was affected by
the storage time and so here we have we
looked at the nanogram per microliter or
yield and found no difference between
samples that were stored over a year to
compared with less than six months in
the middle is the RNA integrity number
analysis which if you remember old
school northern blots basically is a is
a is a in silikal way of looking at the
28s 18s and 5s ribosomal RNA as a marker
of genome of RNA integrity in a score of
six is considered acceptable and we
found no difference in the quality after
depending on storage time so what we
started then getting into our sample
bank and we found that this bryn control
versus malnourished kids we had no
significant difference in the amount of
RNA we achieved and it was an over this
line this dotted line on the left which
was the amount you have to put in for a
WT plus target prep kit and as we gained
familiarity with the procedure
we also identified that they're a very
high RNA quality as well as measured by
the Rin score however and so with the WT
plus target prep which is what we used
was advertised to use 15 anagrams of RNA
and then through you know reverse
transcription and then in vitro
transcription and then labeling and
hybridization to the target prep was
supposed to be it was was touted to be
able to use a whole blood so our however
in our hands we found that with our RNA
isolation process that the first step
here this first purple arrow which is
the which is the first dean see a
complementary RNA purification
quantitation step you require about 834
nanograms for Mike later to proceed we
weren't able to achieve that so we were
kind of stuck there and so what we tried
then is a is a competitor's kit and so
we were able to get some target prep
onto the HTA to point out chips but it
was quite dim as you see here from the
PM mean score so when we use the newgen
we only had a PM mean score of about 131
compared with using that kit on HT a 2
point 0 raised in a cell line you get
over 300 and and if you use the fe
metrics WT plus kit on a cell line on an
HT a 2 point 0 chip you also get a
robust signal so the the downside of
this was that we started we found a
domination of globin transcripts
hemoglobin myoglobin and all these other
ones despite being able to make it
through some of the early QC steps using
this alternative prep so we thought that
globin reduction might improve this so
you have to start with globin reduction
with about a micro gram of RNA and so to
tell you right off we had a hard time
achieving that
and so we in the few samples where we
were able to get enough RNA we did
globin reduction with the goal of
getting 15 anagrams of the input and so
what we see here is that whole blood
again this is that this is that former
step with the whole blood newgen kit
with a very dim chip when we did globin
reduction we improve the signal but it
was still pretty dim and then using the
globe and reduced RNA with the the WT
plus target prep did increase the signal
more but so we did able to get to a high
chip hybridization with the WT plus
target prep however the chips were still
a little bit dim and the we did find
that the globin signal was was gone but
as I mentioned most of the samples had a
pretty limiting factors we would tried
as low as 20 nanograms of input with the
WT plus but with no success how f so
then miraculously for us FP came out
with the WT pico target prep I won't
walk you through all of this but
basically I'll highlight the fact that
there's a much reduced input that is
primarily due to this amplification step
with attack polymerase and so we tried
this on one of our some of our samples
and we found that we needed to modify
just a little bit by at this CRNA
amplification step moving from nine
cycles as recommended up to about 12
cycles but then we started getting good
results and those are presented here
where across our six different batches
we had plenty of input RNA because as
I'll point out here the input is so low
that you need for the Pico kit that this
was a more than ample and so again our
IV t the in vitro transcription step
where you need to hit
834 we had no problem at any of our
batches hitting that and then at the
single stranded cdna step that was even
more normalized and so we had good
reproducible production of target prep
and so these data really and so then we
finally had third of all of our 30
controls in our 30 malnourished samples
done in six batches they're all able to
be hybridized to the HTA 2 point 0 and
so presented here are the relative log
probe intensities for all of the the
chips for and what we found is that
there are a couple of outliers which
left us with 57 out of 60 samples are
exiting within bounds relative long
probe intensity so they can be compared
and so these are data that are really
just a couple of weeks old so we're
still thinking to the bioinformatics
analysis and so I'm not able to present
that today what I can say is we didn't
see any batch or group effects and we
were able to get almost our whole cohort
here and so some of the conclusions and
lessons that we learned is that we were
able to use the wtp coke it to isolate
60 whole genome transcriptomes from
whole blood RNA that were filled
preserved and that globin reduction was
indeed not necessary with WT Pico our
preliminary bioinformatics tells us that
globins are nowhere near dominating as
they used to be so they're actually so
the power of these chips is actually
expected to be quite good and so the
lessons are really to you know optimize
the whole blood sample and storage
collect before you even begin and then
the quantitation of method is important
when we were limited getting to these
limiting samples when we were working
with the WT plus kit we found a big
discrepancy between nanodrop
quantitation and the fluorometric
quantitation and whereas and so the
fluorimetric connotation was when
were much more reflective of what of the
inputs that were necessary and so the
fluorimetric connotation is now standard
at uvm and so our next steps are really
to try to undergo a gene set expression
analysis to determine functional immune
modules genes that are coordinate lee
regulated within immune cell subsets and
then that will help to inform some more
downstream experiments which want to
thank a lot of people from the
University of Vermont vaccine testing
center our advanced genome technology
center for all their hard work and
getting this off the ground our
bioinformatics shared resource billpay
tree and Caitlin Naylor of the
University of Virginia who were involved
or instrumental for the provide study
and also the the study team in Dhaka who
helped performed 15 clinic visits over
two years on 700 kids which is quite
remarkable and lastly I'd like to thank
the families for their participation
thank you both dr. diehl and dr. Mallory
now we're going to open up with question
and answers and dr. Daly the first
question is for you let's see with some
great questions coming in okay just feel
why did you choose micro area instead of
RNA sequencing we chose we chose
microarray because we felt that we
didn't really need the sequence
information our budget was limited and
we used HTA to point o because what we
were most interested in is information
on relative gene expression and a
potentially alternative splicing and
with just a pilot study of 60 kids we
didn't feel we did not our statistics
indicated we didn't have the power for
single nucleotide polymorphism analysis
which is really a huge asset for RNA
seek and so we that's that's that's why
thank you dr. Dale ok dr. mine area
business for you one human cell types
are present in feces that you expect to
be measuring mrna expression from is
this june is its loft off epithelial
tissue could a population of cells
simply be increasing in the RNA sample
and not expression of certain genes in
window
excellent question so you know because
we really wondered ourselves just what
kind of cells we would be sampling and
seeing in there there definitely are
epithelial cells from the intestine and
they're definitely a host of different
in illogical active cells t-cells
b-cells dendritic cells and macrophages
are they present in the same proportions
as they are in the tissue probably not
they'll probably have more of a
propensity for certain cells to shed
than others and we're not particularly I
mean if we could get biopsy samples from
you know 100 or 200 children that would
really be informative in a different way
of this particular condition but we
can't you know if you're imagining these
are free-living kids who aren't and
symptomatic and particularly distressed
and we can't do enter an endoscopy or
anything on them and just to mention
also you know the quality of our of our
RNA that we're looking at here is a lot
less than what Shawn's talking about so
we're looking at written numbers of
three to five or so and in he see he's
got a more concentrated sample and yes
but yes so definitely we can find
something that looks like a biomarker
find something it looks like
pathophysiologic physiology from the
feast fecal perspective is that the
whole story probably not is that enough
of the story to get us on the road to
helping these kids who are so stunted
we're hoping so
I'm sorry we all have time for any more
questions I would like to once again
thank dr. mark maneri and dr. Sean deal
for their presentations I would also
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions we would like to thank our
sponsor affymetrix for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand through April
fourth 2017 labret will alert you via
email when it's ready for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's mighty bend thanks for joining
us until next time goodbye